i got attacked by one of those
crazy masked things considering this is
a show where people are
constantly getting attacked by crazy
masked things this seems like a given
and an unnecessary part of the
previously on section can we arrow in
the present already
yeah this visual works roll commercials
well now we know in this universe that
santa is an [ __ ]
show begins with a flashback to catch up
to the present cliche also
isn't it enough that we already have to
deal with the what oliver was doing five
years ago in every episode then on top
of that you give us present day
flashbacks too many flashbacks show too
many
also also office christmas parties
taking pills without immediately
drinking anything
you know these days you're the closest
thing to a partner i got happy holidays
good to know that detective lance is
okay with the arrow this episode coin
toss landed in the positive
this gives us just enough time to sort
of like the guy before he turns into an
absolute [ __ ] again
you have 48 hours or the citizens of
starling we'll see what the league of
assassins is capable of
oh yeah and it's real serious business
because these guys are willing to dampen
the floors and haul in braziers for
dramatic effect
you don't want these people to [ __ ] with
you sarah is dead
unless of course show decides to throw
her in the lazarus pits to resurrect her
and make her one of the leads of a new
spin-off series
but i'm sure that'll never happen laurel
thea
what are you doing here apparently she's
interrupting people at cemeteries who
are clearly trying to spend some time
with their deceased loved ones
i think the uh who are you talking to
nobody i just come here
sometimes if you ever randomly meet a
person in a graveyard and they reply
that they're not talking to anyone and
like to randomly hang out in the
cemetery either leave them alone or
call the police yeah no one can ever
know
why because if anyone found out that
someone is lighting real candles around
the cemetery they'll find out this is a
massive fire hazard
wait no hey guys someone really should
know about this gravesite over candling
unless it's about how i left after the
kiss i can explain yeah
i can explain does either explanation
involve a skip because that's the part
i'm looking forward to
i have to go work
but you're at work that could be code
let her poop in peace man
but the str markers are degraded so it's
taking a little bit longer
it can't take any longer expecting
science to bend your timeline
this article states that star labs was
once touted as starling city's
technological jewel
which is weird because star labs is
located in central city
who killed sarah
you did some people think this music
indicates increased tension
but if the arrow has taught me anything
it just means whatever you see while the
music plays is a red herring by the end
of this episode we'll find out that
oliver's pet hamster was behind the
whole
thing well that sample is a match for 12
out of the 13
str's the odds of that they're
impossible
assuming that star labs reassembled this
genome properly did your fancy computer
take that into consideration
the hamster did it we all know it's true
it's malcolm merlin
oh well then merlin hid successfully for
two years
from the police and the league he's good
at covering his tracks
so we uncover them nah considering you
pressed like 13 keys on the keyboard and
instantly pulled up all these images of
malcolm
you'll have something in no time the
road ends at a private landing strip
just outside starling city
and you know that by looking at this
incredibly zoomed out world map
how once you see these as jazz hands it
really kind of changes the intensity of
the moment i think you said merlot was
keeping his distance from
thea that he hadn't had any contact
really diggle because earlier you said
roman was in quarter mile tease with
theo when this was going down so if you
knew merlin was with thea why is it a
surprise they got off the plane together
maybe it wasn't your dna oliver maybe it
was theis so if oliver had 12 out of the
13 markers on the arrow that killed
sarah but his half-sister is the killer
wouldn't that mean that there were fewer
markers on the arrow
unless they are twins man i can't wait
for that reveal at the end of the
episode
again holy sh that is a major red flag
right he's tracking felicity's location
good thing she's going to let him have
it when they talk you know instead of
clearing the air about a kiss
you were also pretty wrong when you said
i regret kissing you sho has time for
this which it doesn't because there is
literally a ticking clock that could end
with 50 of starling city citizens being
murdered but you know
talk about dead girlfriends i don't
understand doesn't your father know
if he knew about sarah he couldn't take
it and i can't lose anyone else
but you'll be fine mom plus you're super
disposable to me making a batman villain
an arrow villain cliche
return to starling city be merciless but
roz and his crew are in [ __ ] nanda
perbaat
which is located somewhere in the hindu
kush so these hop skips and jumps
they're taking back and forth are bull
and if they really are almost at the end
of the 48 hours then nisa ain't getting
back in time to do anything about it
could he not have come up with a
dramatic interest that didn't involve
breaking glass he will have to get
replaced i mean this is his place
he has a [ __ ] key stay away from me
and my father the strategy to run is a
good one and will help you stay alive if
you're ever attacked in your home again
good thing you'll do that also did did
she leap off a high-rise
balcony to her death just now she's not
even wearing her superhero belt of plot
convenience
check your phone i can wait maybe start
with that next time
what if ollie had broken your neck
before he had the chance to see the
video
also why is merlin still alive at this
point trying to keep him involved on
this show is one of the most bizarre
story lines it was like lincoln still
including and helping teabag out after
three seasons of prison break
do you ever wonder who records these
incredibly important plot twists first
the shot off the plane and now this 4k
knight video of thea killing sarah
no just me okay oliver if you fight
razor ghoul
he'll kill you no he won't he will but
also won't
during the undertaking merlin told me
that i couldn't win
because i didn't know what i was
fighting for
now i do well that should work then raz
is stronger a much more skilled fighter
and has had decades of assassination
training
but ollie has that can-do attitude this
location is consecrated ground for the
league
a place for the settlement of blood
debts if
one survives the climb and what about
the people who have no blood debt do
they have to climb up there too
and you make them pay
and you make them suffer i suppose it's
no real surprise that these important
motherly moments don't make it to
hallmark too bad
i bet revenge cards would be really
popular in this universe what are you
gonna use it for
to protect the people of this city and i
want you
to help apparently felicity's
superpowers falling into the job of
being
the guy in the chair for every superhero
in starling city
and i am so afraid that razal ghul is
going to use your humanity against you
turns out that's not really an issue and
oliver fights like and is stamped pretty
easily so maybe everyone should be a
little more concerned about his combat
skills
i'm someone that will do whatever
whatever
it takes to save my sister which
includes backing yourself up to the
cliff and ceasing to fight while the
demon head blathers on
good plan remove your shirts this is
custom it's also in the contract that we
must see amilabs at least once per
episode and thank god for that am i
right
the bonus to this shirtless fight is
that if their swords fail they can
nipple fight to death because those
things have to be razor sharp in this
weather
here's a strange moment when oliver has
been throat chopped but somehow loses
his ability to fight back or do anything
cool
i mean the story needs him to be stabbed
and fall down i get that but with
all of oliver's training you'd think
that a throat chop wouldn't drop him to
his knees
ollie survives this i mean yeah i
haven't seen any episodes past this but
the show is called
arrow not arrows annoying friends so
anyone who has
ever watched a television show knows
that olly is not dead this is a
mid-season cliffhanger of lies
when we get to 20 tell me i'm gonna
throw up
hey you know what else we poke fun at
music videos some shits have sins too
trust me and we're more than willing to
point the counter at the teites the
beavers the billies and many more check
out music videos in today
what are you doing here hello peter
what's happening this location is
consecrated ground for the league
a place for the settlement of blood
debts if
one survives
are we okay no man
i'm pretty far from okay
bye your parents death
was not your fault